after six months of hard graft my bad
boys bakery has finally been thrown a
lifeline cafe Nero have agreed to give
our lemon treacle slices a trial for a
week by tomorrow my brigade have got to
have 1100 bait and ready to go but I've
had some devastating news Paul Wyatt has
been working at my Savoy Grill
restaurant for three weeks but I've just
heard he might be back on drugs
I suppose horse you know reflection on
my little brother so it's like here we
go
this guy that got dealt that
dysfunctional card and through no fault
of his own initially he's found himself
in the [ __ ] however I'm just gonna ask
him straight we can't tolerate that aye
sir
I thought Paul was ready to work but
putting him in a busy kitchen like the
Savoy could have been a mistake what was
on the trolley today
like a lamp how are you good how you
feeling yeah good and you sure you can
manage 50 hours a week I mean you don't
think you wanna pull back a little bit
and just pace yourself try and see are
you in control and a big question for me
is have you stayed clean because I heard
from inside that you did relapse you've
taken something no you haven't
No so that slice I want to support Paul
but I know from personal experience
addicts don't always tell the truth deep
down inside you know he's he's suffering
but he's got to go through that turn
around
only he can do it and there's been a
void in his life so
back in prison the rookies have been put
to work and the test for expert guidance
well now is a fully fledged production
kitchen this is turned into a business
now
handle with care is tricky
it's tricky now though and it makes you
uh David I've never seen your hand so
steady pretty good indeed yeah
it's really good you had nozzle nice and
clean every last one of these slices has
got to be perfect
trust me I mean kapha near will be the
first on the phone if any sent back or
any issues complaints problems they'll
be on my case with her [ __ ] harpy
every single slice has got to be checked
for nuts and bolts on the way out I'm
hoping our own metal detector might
speed things up what hit me baby let's
go especially with test for out the
controls it doesn't get any better than
this does it and packaged literally
hours after was cooked you'll never get
any fresh in this weight test and I go
too fast you know slow down but cheese
underneath it I'd be saying that to you
six months ago slow down
[ __ ] what happened
maybe I spoke too soon stop the wire
time but it's a false alarm
Tesla's too fast for his own good ok
chess
hit me yeah let's go we're back in back
in business the bad boys bakery's first
major order is going to be sold in 11
cafe narrow stores across southwest
London I'll see you tomorrow
just remember by the time you wake up
tomorrow morning yeah the product would
be in cafe narrow yeah sorry well done
Brad what's that mean I don't want it to
just be that bam bam make on one little
TV program and that's it you know I mean
I won't have a people to be able to arm
get this feeling that we're getting
right now